speaking of spinning Trump wants to
liberate the states that isn't they do
it spinning but you know here we go
where I talk about the news nice segue
nice excellent segue so earlier today I
saw these tweets from Donald Trump and
it was what he's like liberate Michigan
I don't even know it means liberate
Michigan liberate Virginia and save your
great Second Amendment is under siege
and liberate Minnesota now apparently
this has caused uproar the founder of
The Young Turks is shocked saying if
anyone commits violence against
officials in Michigan Minnesota or
Virginia real Donald Trump should be
impeached again I'm not joking he
clearly incited violence
he's a deranged madman and we have to
get him out of office before he does
more damage this is unprecedented when
what I you know a man that really is
kind of losing losing his edge we lost
it yeah I'm sorry you're right I gotta
say it he lost his edge yeah he used to
be fell off I like the young turks well
they just watch him and be like you know
this is pretty legit like he's always
had weird things going on yeah but they
used to be anti-establishment now
they're pseudo anti-establishment yeah
it's like I heard that he wanted to like
he was trying to convince his employees
to not go into the union yeah it's like
yep why would you want that and then he
started complaining of the airline
that's an old video that's an old video
I know but still like when it's surfaced
I was like is this guy for real
yeah yeah it's a it's a video of him
talking into his phone being like this
airlines not getting me on this flight
why I demand it
why would you post that don't you know
who I am oh no no they don't you're a
youtuber yeah none of us expect any
recognition from regular people right if
I was on the cover doesn't matter how
famous you think you are you're still
just a regular human being
I mean he's famous but come on man it
doesn't matter
he was walking no no no if he was
walking on the street people are gonna
be like whoo yeah if you walk up
somebody and say do you know Genk ugurus
they're gonna be like what I'm sorry
what did you just ask me a question was
that it was that what did you say is
that a name or junk is that of its best
some food jank
huger is his name though but oh no I
don't know that it's no no I don't never
heard it's funny because he likes to
he's really got this
thing about him where he really brags
about the viewership of The Young Turks
and I'm just like bro chill man could
you could you like it's it's one thing
when I when we rag on other networks
you're like doing miserably like CNN's
ratings are dropping dramatically all
the time and I try to be fair and say
their YouTube ratings are like 300
million in the past month
keep in mind YouTube props him up but
it's really weird when he tweeted this
recently there's an article it says Joe
Biden's losing the Internet
you know there's no left-wing YouTube or
whatever and you was like what about the
Young Turks we get way more views I'm so
angry that the New York Times won't
recognize me just do your thing men said
it's not complaining anyway yes exactly
I didn't want to I don't caring I didn't
want to go find a tangent about the
Young Turks but I do feel like they've
kind of like started spiraling yeah
because it's like they're chasing the
tribe instead of chasing the principal
mm-hmm but anyway I wanted to highlight
that to show you just how angry and
outraged everyone was that Donald Trump
tweeted these three things I got to be
honest you want to know what I thought
the first thing I thought when I saw
these tweets from Trump I thought this
huh how's it I just I saw its ways like
uh you know the president tweeted again
do you think after this many years you'd
be like yeah he said it's unprecedented
are you kidding me I thought it was
unprecedented when he tweeted that one
was a horse face I didn't hear he
tweeted that stormy Daniels head Oh
stormy Dana's right he called her horse
face
yeah the funniest thing about it is that
he allegedly slept with her so rare you
know what man if you can't have a sense
of humor about these things right what
would it be blinks gonna happen like
Trump's gonna say something stupid and
then the world's gonna blow up yeah he
really doesn't care what people he
doesn't care
no he clearly doesn't care yeah well he
likes that yeah exactly something I
learned that people unlike he doesn't
care
so here's ya get back to it look at this
look at this the tweets which marked
Trump's most aggressive calls yet for
state economies to reopen I mean
technically but what are these tweets
mean liberate them from who him right
from the governor's it's it's for the
coronavirus duh there there there I
would call these tweets silly there I
don't think they're meant to be literal
calls to revolution
the president right I think he's just
like it's a rallying a bunch of
protesters and you know what these
protesters that we have the story from
William a week I chose this this art
this publication of purpose because it
from Portland so they're super biased
but they're like right-wing protesters
are planning reopen America rallies at
state capitals in Oregon and Washington
and a bunch of other places and I
imagine these guys with their American
flags saw the president tweet this and
they said yeah yeah there's a tweet that
I'm trying to find right now Neil
deGrasse Tyson said it he said you know
there's two different I wanted I wanted
to read I couldn't find it but basically
boy says is there's two like conundrums
right now and it's like you know what
the first one is man I really want to
ready - here we go I just I just forgot
it yeah yeah here we go he goes my gosh
there's so many things that make no
sense to this Neil deGrasse Tyson
frequently tweets things that make no
sense no I
she has there's so much random stuff I'm
seeing that well you pull it out and
yeah a little bit more this will she was
going on a group ohso oh here we go a
group calling itself liberate Minnesota
staged a protest Friday afternoon
outside the residents of the state
governor Tim waltz live streamed video
of the protests showed throngs of people
packed closely outside the residents
many waving pro-trump signs and flags
few participants appeared to be wearing
masks or other protective gear yeah they
don't care well it's been deleted he
deleted tweet the to eat has been
deleted the one that I was about to read
it why what was it about it was
basically him saying there's if you
don't have dandruff why do you use
dandruff shampoo and if the state
doesn't have many kovat cases why aren't
we open yet basis right the point being
that the point became it's working right
the treatments were didn't that
everything's kind of on the decline like
why are we still in lockdown we should
be basically calling it out well he was
basically saying we should be locked in
no I think but he's saying no no no I
guess I guess it could be perceived
either way the point is it's to prevent
dandruff thing was a reference to head
and shoulders commercial right all right
where the guy is talking to the woman
and she sees head and shoulders in the
bathroom and she goes head and shoulders
but you don't have dandruff exactly
right he's using it so the point he was
trying to make was I see him the reason
when I have a lot of case
because we're locked down and that's a
fair point does make sense so I'm seeing
a bunch of people and this is the
weirdest thing to me they're like and
it's not the biggest group but there's
enough of them and they and they're
high-profile saying see they were
projecting two hundred thousand now what
the real number is only forty thousand
right they were wrong it's like no no no
that the the viral tweet right now is
that the the guys like my doctor said I
would die if I don't do this medicine
well I took the medicine and didn't die
I guess he was wrong right however as
much as that's true the the other the
other thing that's really really minded
numbing to me cuz they're even even like
people I know and like people I like
friends of mine who are tweeting about
dr. Phil okay like oh this guy's not
even a real doctor what do you got a PhD
dude he's a clinical psychologist he was
on Fox talking about the psychology of
people and how they're gonna get
depressed and lonely and it's gonna be
traumatic so you know we need to
reconsider Ryota we need to consider
opening up these states yeah and so he
gets slammed across the board by
everybody
you know I've found you know look we've
got a bunch of states that have locked
down it's been devastating 22 million
jobless claims you've got you've got
whitmer in in Michigan which is like the
most egregious governor yes she's
basically like what she did this
interview where she goes everybody you
know complaining about these lock downs
but it's snowing anyway so the things
about like not being able to go
gardening well it's gonna snow anyway oh
my god I'm like right right I love the
the Patrick Henry joke it's like the the
famous quote from Patrick Henry give me
liberty or give me death unless it snows
you know cuz then alright no Liberty if
it's no right yeah no Liberty for
anybody it's snowing your phone but that
was another viral tweet from hers and a
lot of people think she's just trying to
get press attention positive or negative
so that she can get that VP ticket or
whatever I don't know whatever some
people are thinking that she's like
lighting herself on fire because by
doing this weird stuff they're just like
that's what I think chief laws hist to
see that so I would be so we had we had
somebody comment in the superjet about
this the other day about not be able to
buy seeds you can buy seeds
but the law that the executive order she
signed her whatever said that certain
stores over a certain size like Walmart
and stuff had to close most of these
sections including gardening in or
whatever yeah that does make sense so
that meant you couldn't buy seats but
you could still go to some places and
buy seeds I'm sure you know III don't
know if Walmart wouldn't win some to you
but then she actually made the point
that you couldn't go gardening because
of the the the the order she signed so
you know okay so you sure you can buy
the seeds but you can't go and buy
gardening supplies that's the weirdest
thing ever
these got the this is the problem with
government overreach they think they
know what is essential and what isn't
yeah and they don't the example the
exact example I gave uh what if I don't
know a pipe burst in your house right
and you need some of that good ol flex
tape you know flex tape commercials
great laps the thing bone it really does
work wonders um flexing of sauce well
what if they close down the the hardware
section saying nobody needs this yeah
and you're like I've got a water main
break in my house and I need something
flex tape will do the job and they're
like I'm sorry sections closed that's
essential man your house floods you
become homeless what do you do they
think they know they don't I'm like they
said like the hardware section was shut
down flooring and stuff like what if you
get it well what if a hole forms in your
floor like you know I don't know some
kid drops a bag of bowling balls and I
don't know I don't know what kids are
doing these days and they got a hole in
your floor yeah so you go to you go to
try go to Home Depot and they're like
first of all you can't come without a
mass and you gotta go get a mask yeah
and that's that's fine I guess I mean
where do you buy mass other than that
was I get a mess well I guess I would go
to Home Depot and get a mass that was
actually something that happened to us
when we went to Home Depot but if you
didn't have a mess what would you do
just like right pick your shirt oh no
you can't so we had to like wrap a
shredder on her face but I was like we
were they're like you can't come without
a mask I was like but you you get you
guys sell them at us what do i where do
I go to man they actually have masks to
buy or oh I don't know I was like
whatever man I'd register it on my face
tight with a shoelace and they're like
that's fine yeah that's the point the
the reason authoritarianism doesn't work
it's very very simple
one person does not know everything and
definitely one thing people do know each
person knows Lydia can but you can if
somebody is an individual then they're
gonna make the right
for them so they're not no no they're
not no they're not well no I mean it
would definitely be biased towards what
they want right that's the better way to
put it yeah they would make the right
choice Vinson when when when a bunch of
people I ride around i riding around on
Rascals in a Walmart that's ordering a
gallon of coke with their you know
double cheese extra pepperoni pizza I
know there's there are serious problems
but hey I'll tell you what there's a
bias towards what they actually need to
function you know your kid drop the
bowling balls in your floor you're gonna
know that you can't the Flex tape well
it's more along you're a neat game you
need wood right it's the whole floor if
if the kid died through a bowling ball
at the water pipe and it broke that what
normally breaks water mains I don't know
freezing Oh your kids spilled the liquid
nitrogen and then a bowling ball
weird weird people in this house kids do
these days playing with I see the
YouTube videos where they're spraying
everybody with liquid nitrogen or
whatever it is that's oh no you're they
did I'd be it's actually make more sense
if they were using like a torch to light
a nickel ball here's those videos or
batteries no the kid got the hydraulic
press okay all these all these lucky for
you I dunno how to fix that what but but
so so we are being silly but yeah I
think you know the point I was gonna
make about the economic shutdown like it
is true that if someone says you took
your medicine you didn't you you like
you got better mm-hmm okay we we shut
everything down we didn't get hit as
hard but now we need to start reopening
the economy's the funny thing the reason
I brought up dr. Phil on this one is
because I see all these people yelling
at him and Andrew Cuomo said the exact
same thing I just I'm just so sick of it
man yeah Andrew Cuomo says it it's it's
law it's the word of the Lord like oh
man Andrew Cuomo he should be President
like I hear that all Alyssa Milano
called him America's presenting the same
thing yeah as the president yes yes and
dr. Phil and what everyone's yelling at
him and this whole dr. Phil things so
stupid he's not an MD it's like yet his
comment was about the psychological
health health
the country and that's what he's a
doctor at facts don't matter don't
matter I don't get it I mean no I think
we all do get it I think I think we say
I don't get it as kind of like a
colloquial frustration yes you're right
but we do get it these people don't know
it they don't care it's just a bunch of
Stooges like trying to fit in yeah it's
like a bunch of you know what you could
do I'd be willing to bet you could hire
a bunch of people to do something really
really weird like you know just dance
randomly in a spot and random people
would join in
I bet oh look at me go on like going the
circle I like where your head's at maybe
maybe we should maybe we should do it
something like that's like a social
experiment in cast IRL dance a social
experiment now where we threw our where
we proved that you can you can trick
people into doing ridiculous things or
believe in ridiculous things okay by
surrounding them by enough people who
are saying or doing the same thing yeah
that's it there's actually a couple that
I keep talking about 100 humans in the
show is kinda silly and some of the
experience experiments they do are a
little biased the way they do it so it
kind of annoys me but sometimes it's
really cool and they do this one where
they have a hundred people stand in like
a grid then they take half of them away
and then they teach the other half how
to do a dance and then they bring the
other half back and they're like alright
everybody we're time to do the dance and
they were seeing how many of the people
that weren't there started doing the
dance and all of them started were like
totally thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you